Film Courage: Peter, what makes a good story?
Peter Russell: Embarrassment.
Truth.
Ask yourself (and you do it alone in a room),
write down on a piece of paper, the ten most
embarrassing things (secrets) in your life
you would never want anyone to know.
Now we all have them, write down ten of them…you
don’t ever want to show this to anybody,
you don’t have to.
But those ten embarrassing secrets will fuel
almost all the stories you’re ever going
to tell in your life.
Every story you tell if going to come out
of those horrible embarrassments because they
are what’s wounded you and they start when
you’re little and it’s usually our parents
that wound us.
Sometimes it’s a dirty ole’ uncle, sometimes
it’s a neighbor, but it’s usually our
parents.
So if you can understand what those wounds
are, you’re going to be able to write ten
compelling characters all having behaviors
that are compensations for that wound.
Like I said, one of mine was that my Mommy
didn’t love me, but it came out in Body
Dysmorphia, that won’t be the case for you.
The one wound – “I’m unlovable,” look
how it worked for Don Draper (AMC’s television
series Mad Men).
He became Mr. Handsome.
Everything he did was seductive.
Yes?
So that’s a difference, because everyone
is different to how they react to the core
wound.
This is the most potent way to tell a great
story and it’s about character.
You know, Blake Snyder, wrote a great book
called SAVE THE CAT, but he didn’t talk
much about character.
And so this lecture I gave yesterday which
was killing the cat is sort of like what else
you need to know about story if you want to
write a compelling story today.
Character is something that seems like a black
box for a lot of writers.
So I’m suggesting what’s more interesting
in your life than what happened to you?
Your secrets.
If you can’t get interested in your own
secrets, you are going to write a boring character.
Or sometimes you see teachers say “Here
is a list of things.
Write down a list of character attributes,
Well they like tea, they like…I don’t
know…diapers.”
It seems so arbitrary, right?
Who cares?
Think about your own wound, you like what
you have avoided and what you still avoid.
And I guarantee, “…Like she’s gonna
really say that?
I don’t want to reveal that about myself.”
Well, you’re going to have a boring story
if you don’t and even writers who are very
successful and they tell me “I never do
any of that crap.
I’m completely unanalyzed and I don’t
need analysis.
One page of their script reveals reveals all
of that damage, whether they want it to or
not.
It’s right there.
It’s what they write about.